Hey there, Will Arnett here. Welcome to SmartLess, our podcast where Jason Bateman, Sean Hayes and I each week, one of us brings a guest that the other two don't know about. And this week is no exception. We get real into it. Most of the time we just mess around with each other and then the guest has to be embarrassed. So let's get right to the podcast. I have a t-shirt on today that says Camaro. And you know that that's a car, right? That's not like a brand of olive oil or something. Camaro, it's a domestic car. Okay, made in the United States. Yeah. Who of the three of us was the last person to drive through a McDonald's Burger King type of thing? Sean, not yesterday. He didn't drive through yesterday,
大家好，我是威尔·阿奈特。欢迎收听 SmartLess，这是我们的播客节目，由杰森·贝特曼、肖恩·海斯和我共同主持。每周我们其中一个人会带一个另外两人都不知道的神秘嘉宾来。这周也不例外。我们总是玩得很真。大多数时候我们只是互相开玩笑，然后让嘉宾感到尴尬。所以我们直接进入正题吧。我今天穿了一件印着“卡迈罗”（Camaro）的T恤。你知道那是一辆汽车，对吧？它可不是什么橄榄油的牌子。卡迈罗，这是一辆国产车。好吧，在美国制造的。是的。我们三个人当中，最后一次开车去麦当劳或汉堡王那种地方的人是谁？肖恩，不是昨天。他昨天没开车去，
but I know that he had fast food yesterday. Oh, so you go in and you sit down, you bring your own place mat and stuff like that? No. Make a night of it? Could you imagine? Scotty, get dressed. Yeah, we're going out. Where did you go? I went to Burger Lounge because I like their burgers. That's not fast food. Oh, I didn't know you were going to Burger Lounge. That's so good. I love that place. Isn't that the best? No, fast food, I probably go once every couple of months. Really? And where's your go to? McDonald's. And what do you get? I get a Big Mac, no pickle, a six piece McNaggot sweet and sour sauce, a small fry and maybe a root beer. And that's just for one person? Wait, what dipping sauce
但我知道他昨天吃快餐了。哦，所以你走进去坐下，带上你自己的餐垫之类的东西？不是的。把这当成是一场约会？你能想象吗？斯科蒂，穿好衣服。对，我们要出门了。你去了哪？我去了 Burger Lounge，因为我喜欢他们的汉堡。那不算快餐。哦，我不知道你要去 Burger Lounge。那太棒了。我很喜欢那个地方。那是不是最棒的？不，快餐的话，我大概每几个月去一次。真的吗？你常去哪家？麦当劳。你点什么？我点一个巨无霸，不要酸黄瓜，一份六块的麦乐鸡，配糖醋酱，一份小薯条，可能还会来一杯根汁汽水。这只是一个人的量吗？等等，你吃什么酱
do you do with the? This is fascinating. I do sweet and sour. Sure you do. Wait, Jason, tell me that you don't do fast food. I don't do fast food. Ever. I haven't had fast food in years, but it doesn't mean I wouldn't if we were to hang out. Yeah, let's do it. Well, you go to the Dodgers game and you eat a hot dog. Oh yeah, I have Dodger Dogs. I don't know if that counts. That's actually... You do have Dodger Dogs. I do have Dodger. Well, I have the veggie dogs. God, I'm so... I hate myself. Listen, today we're going to try something a little bit different. All right, we usually have a guest that will educate us about their field, but today we are going to explore more of the human condition. Our guest today has
来搭配？这太迷人了。我选糖醋酱。你当然选那个。等等，杰森，告诉我你从不吃快餐。我不吃快餐。从来不吃。我好几年没吃过快餐了，但这并不意味着如果我们要一起出去玩，我就不会吃。好吧，我们去吃吧。好吧，你去道奇队的比赛现场会吃热狗。哦对，我会吃道奇热狗。我不知道这算不算。这其实……你确实会吃道奇热狗。我的确会吃道奇。好吧，我吃素食热狗。天哪，我太……我讨厌我自己。听着，今天我们要尝试一点不同的东西。好吧，我们通常会请一位嘉宾来给我们科普他们的专业领域，但今天要探讨更多的是人类的生存状态。我们今天的嘉宾
lived a very eclectic life that has taken him through the dangerous seas of the South Pacific and the complicated world of Washington, DC. He has wrestled the powerful forces of the healthcare industry, written a children's book. He's inspired millions and also infuriated thousands. He has never learned to swim, but he is one of our country's greatest fishermen. He suffers from narcolepsy, but his work exists mostly at night. Ladies and gentlemen, Will and Sean, you know him from such films as Delinquents Derby, Brad Stadis, and of course 2015's The Hay Day of Insensitive Bastards. I want you to please give a very warm, smart list welcome to Mr. James Christian Kimmel. Oh wow. Yes. Hi guys. That was an unbelievable
度过了非常丰富多彩的一生，他曾涉足南太平洋危险的海域，也闯荡过华盛顿特区错综复杂的政治世界。他曾与强大的医疗保健行业做过斗争，还写过一本童书。他激励了数百万人，同时也惹怒了数千万人。他从未学会游泳，但他却是我们国家最伟大的渔民之一。他患有发作性睡病，但他的工作主要都在夜间进行。女士们先生们，威尔和肖恩，你们从《Delinquents Derby》、《Brad Stadis》以及2015年的《失控笨蛋的黄金时代》等电影中认识他。请大家用热烈的 SmartLess 欢迎掌声欢迎詹姆斯·克里斯蒂安·吉immel 先生。哦，哇。是的。嗨，伙计们。那真是一个令人难以置信的
misdirect. Yeah, that was a really good intro. It was. I am a pretty good swimmer, but other than that, everything was right. It's the one untruth in there. You really can't swim, by the way. No, I can swim. He's a great swimmer. All right. I've been listening to this podcast, by the way. I've listened to all the episodes and I apologize. I love it. I really do. I enjoy it. Really? I am not typically a person who listens to podcasts because I do not have the time to do it. I mainly listen for the auto zone commercials. And I like the mental health commercials where you guys suddenly get real serious right in the middle of a funny conversation. Yeah, enough around with that. And I love that we actually bundled
误导。对，那开场真的很棒。确实如此。我游泳游得其实挺好，但除此以外，其他全都是真的。那是里面唯一不实的地方。顺便说一句，你真的不会游泳吧。不，我会游泳。他游泳游得很好。好吧。顺便说一句，我一直在听这个播客。我听了所有的节目，我向你们道歉。我很喜欢。真的。我很享受。真的吗？我通常不是那种听播客的人，因为我没有时间。我听播客主要是为了听 AutoZone 的广告。我还喜欢心理健康广告，就是你们在搞笑的对话中间突然变得非常严肃的那种。对，别扯那些没用的了。而且我特别喜欢我们居然把心理健康广告跟“成为贵族”的广告剪在了一起，
the mental health spot against the become a Lord spot where you can buy a square foot of land and those ran back to back. I am actually signed up for that too. I am now Lord Lady of Kimmel. So you bought two squares, a Lord and a Lady Square? Yeah, why not? I mean, what the heck? Yeah. All right. So is the narcolepsy true? It is true. Honestly. Yeah. You suffer from narcolepsy and you take a one pill for and you don't have to worry about falling asleep when you're at a red light. Wait, that's when you just fall asleep at a random time? Yeah. My doctor diagnosed it. I have fallen asleep at red lights. I was once yelled out by a police officer at a red light. The police officer suddenly used
在那儿你可以买下一平方英尺的土地，这两个广告居然是连播的。其实我也注册了那个。我现在是金immel领地的主人/女主人了。所以你买了两平方英尺，一个领主平方和一个夫人平方？对啊，为什么不呢？我是说，管他呢？对。好吧。所以发作性睡病是真的吗？是真的。说实话。对。你患有发作性睡病，然后你吃一种药，你就不用担心在红灯前睡着了。等等，那是那种你会随时随地突然睡着的情况吗？对。我的医生确诊的。我曾在红灯前睡着过。我曾经在红灯前被警察用扩音器大声吼过。那个警察突然用了
that speaker and said, are you awake enough to operate that motor vehicle? And I looked over and said, I am now. For years, I took a pill every day called Pro Vigil. And then I decided to stop taking it. And now I just drink a lot of coffee. And so there's no risk of when you're tooling down the road with Molly and the kids in the back, you just nodding off and taking the family into a light post. It's more difficult when I'm alone, but because Molly will keep you up. The kids will keep you up when you're driving. I will say, I love having narcolepsy. I wouldn't trade it if I had the chance because I fall asleep within four minutes. I lay down and I am out and my wife hates it. I have the
那个喇叭说：“你有足够清醒来驾驶这辆机动车辆吗？”我转过头看着他说：“我现在清醒了。”多年来，我每天都吃一种叫 Provigil 的药。后来我决定停药了。现在我只是喝很多咖啡。所以，当你带着莫利和孩子们在路上开着车，打瞌睡把一家人开进电线杆的风险就没有了吗？当我独自一人时更困难，但因为莫利会让你保持清醒。你开车时孩子们会让你保持清醒。我必须说，我其实挺喜欢有发作性睡病的。如果有机会，我绝对不会用它去换别的，因为我能在四分钟内入睡。我躺下就直接断片了，我老婆恨死这个了。我有
opposite problem. Well, it's because of the crazy McDonald's menu order that you have. Insane. That's healthy at 50, right? It's healthy anytime. All right. So with the caveat that the only professional interviewer on this is Jimmy, here come my crappy questions. Okay. I've combed through your... And by the way, for Jason to comb through something, he's admitted many times, he hasn't combed through his own hair since he was 11. So for him to comb through anything is big. You really are becoming Teen Wolf. Okay. So you were raised Catholic and as a child was also an altar boy. Is that correct?
截然相反的问题。好吧，那是因为你那疯狂的麦当劳点餐单。太疯狂了。50岁时这样还算健康吧？什么时候这样都很健康。好吧。那么，基于这里只有吉米是专业采访者这一前提，我这些糟糕的问题要来了。好吧。我梳理了你的……顺便说一句，对于杰森来说，要去“梳理”什么东西——他已经承认过很多次了，他从11岁起就没梳理过自己的头发。所以对他来说，去梳理任何东西都是一件大事。你真的快变成《狼少年》了。好吧。所以你是天主教家庭长大的，小时候还是个祭童。对吗？
Yeah, I was. That is correct. All right. Let's jump right into religion. Okay. How big is religion in your life? Is it big, small or medium? Well, it is... I definitely have me religious person. I believe in the Lord Jesus Christ. I don't force it on others. It's somewhere below... Like, I guess it would go like pizza, the Mets... Yep. You know, surprises. I don't know. It might even be below tacos. I'm not sure.
对，我是。那是对的。好吧。我们直接切入宗教话题。好吧。宗教在你的生活中占多大比重？是大、小还是中等？嗯，它是……我绝对算是一个有宗教信仰的人。我相信主耶稣基督。我不会把这强加给别人。它大概排在……嗯，我猜大概排在披萨、大都会队……对。你知道的，还有惊喜之后吧。我不知道。它甚至可能排在塔可饼后面。我不确定。
But I was an altar boy for seven years, far, far too long. I was starting to grow breasts. I was still an altar boy. How old were you when religion entered your life? Like, from birth, right? Your parents were... Yeah. I mean, I was baptized. So I guess right at that very moment, a few days after my birth. And how many siblings? I have two siblings, a brother and a sister. I'm the oldest. I grew up mostly in Las Vegas. I had a priest there named Father Bill, with whom I'm still very friendly. And one night
但我当了七年祭童，时间实在太长、太长了。我都开始长胸部了，却还是个祭童。你多大时宗教进入你的生活？比如，从出生开始，对吧？你的父母是……对。我的意思是，我受过洗。所以我想就在那个特定的时刻，在我出生几天后。你有几个兄弟姐妹？我有两个兄弟姐妹，一个哥哥/弟弟和一个姐姐/妹妹。我是老大。我大部分时间在拉斯维加斯长大。我在那儿有个神父叫比尔神父，到现在我们关系都非常好。有一天
at dinner when... This was years ago when the Catholic Church was experiencing a lot of controversy as a result of all these molestations. He didn't get up to Canada, I guess. But yeah, well, there was... We had some trouble. And at dinner one night in Las Vegas with a large group of friends, I loudly and angrily demanded to know why Father Bill had never molested me. I wasn't good enough for you! But he wants you on his podcast. All right, I'm moving on to the next thing I found in my dirty comb. You're a real prankster,
在晚宴上当……那是多年前天主教教会因为虐童丑闻而经历大量争议的时候。他好像没闹到加拿大去吧。但不管怎样，当时……我们遇到了一些麻烦。有一天在拉斯维加斯的一个晚宴上，和一大群朋友在一起，我大声且愤怒地质问，为什么比尔神父从来没有虐待过我？我连被你虐待都不够格吗！但他是想让你上他的播客。好吧，我接着说我在脏梳子里发现的下一件事。你可真是个恶作剧大户，
it sounds like, here. There's several stunts on air, including one that led to an $8,000 loss in advertising. Do you have any recollection of what that might be? What is that? When I was on the radio, you mean? Yeah. This was during the Me and Him show on KZO Key and... You glanced at my Wikipedia page, as well. I just did a comb over of it. I've known you for how long? By the way, speaking of Wikipedia, how many hours have we spent together?
听起来是这样。节目里有几个特技，包括一个导致广告收入损失8000美元的事件。你还记得那可能是什么吗？那是什么？当我在电台工作的时候，你是说？对。那是在 KZO Key 的“我和他”节目期间，而且……你也浏览了我的维基百科页面。我只是用梳子把它的毛梳理了一遍。我认识你多久了？顺便说一句，说到维基百科，我们一起度过多少个小时了？
Will you tell these guys in our listener one of my favorite things you ever did regarding Wikipedia, what you did to our friend Justin Thoreau? Do you remember that? I did one to John Krasinski, where I wrote that his family were the founders and owners of Krasins, the cranberry raisin. It's called Krasins because of Krasinski, and he removed that before I was even finished typing it. He went on and removed it. What did I do to Justin? I forget what I wrote on his... You wrote and you buried it halfway through, so you'd really have to get in there to see it, but you wrote, and Mr. Thoreau cries when he ejaculates.
你能不能告诉这些伙计们以及我们的听众，关于维基百科你做过的我最喜欢的事之一，你对我们的朋友贾斯汀·塞洛克斯做了什么？你还记得吗？我对约翰·卡拉辛斯基做过一次，我写道他的家族是“克拉辛斯”（Krasins，蔓越莓葡萄干）的创始人和所有者。之所以叫 Krasins 是因为卡拉辛斯基，而他在我甚至还没打完字之前就把那条删了。他马上上去删掉了。我对贾斯汀做了什么？我忘了我在他……你写了，而且你把它埋在了中间，所以你真的得仔细看才能发现，你写的是：“塞洛克斯先生射精时会哭。”
That's probably still up. No, no. It only lasted about an hour, so we did this on his birthday, I think. Remember when we screenshotted it and sent it to him and said, happy birthday. The most interesting thing about that is, I know you're not supposed to do that. You're not supposed to screw with Wikipedia. It's a sacred text, and you're also not supposed to write on your own Wikipedia page, but as I recall, we were sitting at that table and I tried to change something on Jen Aniston's page as a joke, and it would not allow it. It actually like...
那可能现在还在。不，不。那只持续了一个小时左右，所以我想我们是在他生日那天做的这事。还记得我们截屏发给他并说“生日快乐”吗？关于这件事最有趣的是，我知道你不该那么做。你不应该胡乱篡改维基百科。这是一部神圣的文本，而且你也不应该在自己的维基百科页面上胡写，但据我回忆，我们当时坐在那张桌子旁，我想作为笑话修改一下詹妮弗·安妮斯顿页面上的东西，结果它不让我改。它简直就像……
She's got a lock on it? There's something I don't know. The Secret Service showed up at your house. It was weird. Then it was interesting to see which celebrities get locked and which don't. Oh, really? I think it puts you in a second tier, yeah. I think there's ads out there soliciting changes on mine. All right, so now that was high jinx during your radio world, and then there was this
她给页面加了锁？有些事我不知道。特勤局甚至出现在你家门口了。这很诡异。然后看看哪些名人页面被锁定，哪些没有，这倒挺有意思的。哦，真的吗？我想这说明你被排在第二梯队了，对吧。我记得网上还有广告招募别人去修改我的页面呢。好吧，所以那是你在电台时期的恶作剧，然后就有了这个
transition? Yeah, I got fired from every radio station, including that one, and that's why I got fired from that station. I don't think it was a prank. You know what I did? I wrote one of these 80s parody songs about the owner of the Seattle Mariners, and the Mariners were not happy, and they canceled their advertising, and then the ad agency, which handled McDonald's, interestingly, canceled McDonald's advertising, and $8,000 sounds like a joke. They lost $8,000 in advertising. It sounds like nothing, but at the time it was about half my annual salary, and the sales
转型？对，我被所有电台开除了，包括那家，这就是我被那家电台开除的原因。我不觉得那是个恶作剧。你知道我做了什么吗？我写了一首关于西雅图水手队老板的80年代恶搞歌曲，水手队很不高兴，他们取消了广告投放，然后广告公司——有趣的是，这家广告公司正好代理麦当劳——也取消了麦当劳的广告，而8000美元听起来像个笑话。他们损失了8000美元的广告费。听起来好像不算什么，但当时那几乎是我年薪的一半，电台的销售
people at the radio station were none too pleased. But surprisingly, television came for you, and you pushed it off and pushed it off to say no thank you, no thank you, but eventually you did say yes to win Ben Stein's money. Why did you say yes there as your first television show? What were like one or two of the things that you were like, that's not for me? I never imagined I'd be in television. I was a radio disc jockey, and my dream was to do morning radio in a major market like LA or Chicago or whatever. That's really what I wanted to do.
人员对此可一点也高兴不起来。但令人惊讶的是，电视界向你伸出了橄榄枝，而你一次又一次地推脱，说谢谢不用了、谢谢不用了，但最终你还是答应去赢取本·斯坦的钱。你为什么把那作为你的第一个电视节目而答应下来？当时有一两件什么事情让你觉得“那不适合我”？我从没想过自己会拍电视。我以前是个电台DJ，我的梦想是在洛杉矶或芝加哥这样的大市场做早间电台节目，诸如此类。那真的是我想做的事。
I didn't like the wacky dudes that are like, hey, good morning to drive time. Good morning, dude. Not like that, but I was on Kevin and Bean's show on K-Rock for five years here in LA, and while I was on that show, I would get calls from TV producers asking me to audition for things, and they were almost always dumb things that I knew weren't going to work. If there was any upfront money, I probably would have gone for some of these jobs, but I remember one show was called Pop Quiz, and basically you had to determine which stories about celebrities were real and which were not real, and I realized very quickly that
我不喜欢那些疯疯癫癫的、喊着“嘿，早安，早高峰”的主持人。早安，老兄。不是那种的，但我曾在洛杉矶 K-Rock 电台的凯文和宾节目呆了五年，在那档节目期间，我经常接到电视制片人的电话，邀请我去试镜各种节目，而几乎总是那些我知道不会成功的蠢节目。如果当时有任何预付款的话，我可能就会接其中一些工作了，但我记得有个节目叫《流行问答》，基本上你得判断哪些关于名人的故事是真的，哪些是假的，而我很快意识到，
because the show taped like six months in advance, the show would make no sense when it went on air, and there was really no way to verify whether the stories were real in the first place, and that the show would never, would not sell and would be a disaster. So my first thing I wanted to make sure was good, and in fact, when a guy named Michael Davies pitched me Win Ben Stein's money, I didn't know who Ben Stein was, and he said, he's the guy in Ferris Bueller's Day Off who says, Bueller, Bueller, and he explained the premise of the show that- I'm in.
因为这个节目提前大约六个月录制，等它播出时就会变得毫无意义，而且根本没有办法去核实那些故事最初是不是真的，这个节目绝对卖不出去，最终会是一场灾难。所以我首先要确保的是节目得好。事实上，当一个叫迈克尔·戴维斯的家伙向我推销《赢取本·斯坦的钱》时，我根本不知道本·斯坦是谁，他说，他就是《春天不是读书天》里那个说“比勒？比勒？”的家伙，然后他向我解释了节目的构思，我——我接了。
You were like, I'm in. That's exactly- I was. Bueller guy, I'm in. I did say that. I really did. I said, that's a funny title, and the game itself sounds like fun, and so- And then I'm sure you were shocked like us to learn about his actual legitimacy.
你当时就说，我接了。那绝对是——我确实这么说了。那个演比勒的家伙，我接了。我真的这么说了。我说，这是一个很好听的节目名，而且游戏本身听起来很有趣，所以——然后我敢肯定你和我们一样，在了解到他的真实学术背景时被震惊了。
Well, yeah, sure. I mean, you know, he wrote for Nixon, he's a law professor, all of these things, and he knows a lot of things, so he was hard to beat, and he and I just happen to have very good chemistry, and that was my first television show. You still talk to him at all? We email about once a week, yeah. Come on. That's nice.
嗯，对，当然。我的意思是，你知道的，他给尼克松写过演讲稿，他是个法学教授，诸如此类，他知道很多事情，所以他很难被打败，我和他恰好有着非常好的化学反应，那成了我的第一个电视节目。你现在还会跟他聊天吗？我们大概每周发一次邮件，吧。拜托。真不错。
Really? Yeah. Sometimes more. Do you think he'd rather play Win Jimmy Kimmel's money now? Probably. He's doing pretty well for himself, but he, you know what, I actually haven't heard from him for a few weeks because he watches the show. Maybe he should drive around the house.
真的吗？对。有时更频繁。你觉得他现在更愿意去玩《赢取吉米·法伦/吉米·坎摩尔的钱》吗？可能吧。他现在过得挺好的，不过，你知道吗，其实我已经有几周没听到他的消息了，因为他会看这个节目。也许他应该开车在房子周围转转。
He watches the show every night, and I haven't been doing the show this summer, so there's less commentary on what's going on in the show. Are you missing it right now, given all that's going on, although I guess there's never a moment when nothing's going on, but what is that like? When you take a little break, you know, stuff happens, and do you come up with like a bit you'd like to do or a joke you'd like to tell, and then you get frustrated that, ah, damn it, we're not on tonight? Yeah.
他每天晚上都看这个节目，而且今年夏天我没做这个节目，所以对节目中发生的事情的评论就变少了。鉴于目前发生的一切，你现在会想念它吗？虽然我想永远都不会有“什么都没发生”的时候，但这是一种什么样的感觉？当你稍微休息一下时，你知道的，事情总会发生，你会不会想出一个你想做的小品或者想讲的笑话，然后就会感到沮丧：啊，该死，我们今晚不播？对。
There are moments where you see like Melania not grabbing Donald's hand or Mike Pence making some ridiculous speech or, you know, Steve Bannon perhaps getting arrested exactly as arrested development began, that you think, oh, I could make something of this, but ultimately it's more fun to do nothing. Right. Yeah. Gotcha. Right.
有些时刻，你会看到比如梅拉尼娅不握唐纳德的手，或者迈克·彭斯发表一些荒谬的演讲，或者，你知道的，史蒂夫·班农可能在《发展受阻》开播的精确时刻被捕，你会想，哦，我可以利用这个做点文章，但归根结底，什么都不做更有趣。对。是的。明白了。对。
I mean, if it was Einstein's money, we went to the man show. Could you do the man show today? Oh, yes. Really? It would be 10 times as popular. Of course I could. It would be. Yeah.
我的意思是，如果是斯坦的钱，我们去了《男人秀》。你今天还能做《男人秀》吗？哦，能。真的吗？它会比以前火十倍。我当然能。会这样的。对。
Well, what network would it be on? Well, we'd have no advertisers, but, but, you know, I don't think- It'd be streaming. I don't think even any of the streaming services would be interested in the show, but I think you'd be able to figure out a platform for a show like that. Yeah. I bet you they would pick it up, right? Somebody definitely would.
好吧，它会在哪个电视网播出？嗯，我们会没有广告商，但是，你知道的，我不认为——它会在流媒体上播。我想甚至没有任何流媒体服务会对这个节目感兴趣，但我觉得你能为这种节目找到一个平台。对。我打赌他们会接手的，对吧？绝对会有人接的。
They'd put it out on YouTube, and it would like- Yeah. It is, you know, you know how people are. It's like the less corporate America wants you to see something, the more you want to see something. Right. Yeah. Of course, it's a show that, at the time, Adam Carolla and I, we quit that show.
他们会把它发到 YouTube 上，然后就会——对。这是，你知道的，你知道人们是怎样的。这就好像越是企业美国不想让你看到什么，你就越想看什么。对。没错。当然，这是一个节目，当时亚当·科罗拉和我，我们辞掉了那个节目。
You know, we were sick of doing the show. We realized that the audience was not necessarily getting what we wanted them to get from it. But I remember really when we looked at each other and knew the show was over, Adam was talking about some, like some dickhead, like dad of a friend he had when he was a kid. And he was using this as an example of what a not interesting, funny person the dad was. He goes, this kid's dad, he always said to me, opinions are like assholes. Everyone has one. And the audience laughed as if that was the first time they heard that.
你知道的，我们厌倦了做那个节目。我们意识到观众不一定能从中得到我们希望他们得到的东西。但我记得当我们看着彼此、知道节目要结束时，亚当正在谈论一个……某个混蛋，比如他小时候一个朋友的老爸。他用这个来举例说明那个爸爸是多么不有趣、不好笑的人。他说，这孩子的爸爸总是对我说：“意见就像屁股，人人都有一个。”而观众大笑，仿佛那是他们第一次听到这句话。
So we looked at each other like we got to get the fuck out of here. Yeah. Now, so I apologize that I did see the show, but it's been a while. I forget that basically it was unapologetic misogyny, but meant to be sort of satirical a la the Stephen Colbert report sort of mocking way. Well, yeah, I mean, it was it was blurrier than that. It was just like, I don't know, it was more like, I think Al Bundy would be a character that would be closer to what we're doing.
所以我们看着彼此，心想我们得赶紧他妈的离开这里。好吧。现在，所以我为我看过这个节目道歉，但这已经是好久以前的事了。我忘了它基本上是毫不掩饰的厌女症，但旨在具有某种讽刺意味，类似于史蒂芬·科尔伯特报告的那种嘲讽方式。嗯，对，我的意思是，它比那要模糊一些。这更像是，我不知道，它更像是，我觉得阿尔·邦迪这个角色会更接近我们当时在做的事情。
It was just like a celebration of all the stupid shit guys do and like. And also we used Oprah kind of as our, our touchstone. I mean, at the time my ex-wife was watching Oprah every day and then yelling at me when I got home from work for things she'd seen on Oprah. And this is Oprah before it was kind of a, you know, celebrity vehicle, you know, where Julia Roberts would be on talking about gardening. This was like when, you know, like your husband's on the down low kind of Oprah. And so I kind of had enough of that and I went into a meeting with some producers who
这简直就像是对男人做的所有蠢事的庆祝，以及……而且我们还把奥普拉当作我们的某种准绳。我的意思是，当时我的前妻每天都在看奥普拉，然后当我下班回家时，会因为她在奥普拉上看到的东西对我大喊大叫。这是奥普拉变成那种，你知道的，名人宣传工具（比如朱莉娅·罗伯茨上节目谈论园艺）之前的奥普拉。这就像是那种，你知道的，“你老公是个深柜”的那种奥普拉。所以我差不多受够了那些，然后我去开会见了一些制片人，他们
wanted me to do a daytime talk show for women. And I knew that not even my wife liked me and that that would not fly. And Carol and I had been doing radio together and we decided to do the opposite of that show. And it was on for a while, wasn't it? It was on for four seasons with us. And then they kept doing it for another season with Joe Rogan and Doug Stanhope to go as the host of that show.
想让我为女性做一个日间脱口秀。而我知道甚至连我老婆都不喜欢我，那档节目绝对行不通。我和科罗拉一直在合作电台节目，我们决定做那个节目的反面。而且它播了一段时间，不是吗？它跟我们一起播了四季。后来他们又让乔·罗根和道格·斯坦霍普去接替主持，又多播了一季。
Oh, shit. Yeah. So when I see you like hosting the Emmys again this year, which I can't wait for and see how that's going to go virtually, right? Yeah. And doing that, doing millionaire, doing your show, because your show is such a grind, I can't imagine. And I know you've heard me say this to a million times and other people say, how do you do
哦，操。对啊。所以当我看到你今年再次主持艾美奖时——我简直迫不及待了，看看这次会以虚拟形式如何进行，对吧？——对。还有做那个，主持《百万富翁》，还有做你的节目，因为你的节目简直是个苦差事，我无法想象。我知道你听我向一百万人说过这话，别人也说过，“你怎么能每天都做那个”
that every single day? It just seems like such a mountain to climb every day. You call Jimmy every day and say that. Yeah, I do. How are you still alive? Again, I watched last night. How did you do it last night? With a continental accent.
每天都像是一座必须攀登的高山。你每天都给吉米打电话说这个。对，我确实打。你怎么还没死？再说一次，我昨晚看了。你昨晚是怎么做到的？带着欧洲大陆的口音。
And he's like, fuck man, I'm taking this really personally. How are you? Hey, it's Sean again. I just saw. You should kill yourself with this schedule. But because it's such a grind, because you're always out there, do you still get a rush like to do the hosting gigs? It seems like you so love working.
然后他就像是：操，老兄，我把这事当真了。你好吗？嘿，我是肖恩又来了。我刚看到。你真该用这个日程把自己累死。但因为这是一份苦差事，因为你总是冲在前面，你还会对主持工作感到那种冲动吗？看起来你那么热爱工作。
Is that true? No, I love it. You don't, right? If it goes great, I'm like, okay, good, that's good. I asked you this the other day and again, I think I may have blacked out during your answer. So remind me, you've got to definitely take a little bit of a private, you're way too humble to do it outwardly, but inside, you must smell the roses about where you are, what you've done.
是真的吗？不，我太爱了。你才不，对吧？如果效果绝佳，我会想：好吧，不错，这很好。我前几天问过你这个问题，而且再次申明，我想我在你回答的时候可能已经大脑一片空白了。所以提醒我一下，你肯定得享受一点私人的——你太谦虚了，不会表露出来，但在内心深处，对于你所处的位置、你所做过的事，你一定有一种“细嗅蔷薇”的感悟吧。
I mean, we just kind of went through a little bit of your early career. I mean, you are absolutely at the top of your mountain, you haven't done any sort of gymnastics to your personnel. Like you've stayed who you are, and you are at the top of what you do. There's got to be some kind of a rush with that, yes? I mean, you should be very proud, I'm sure you are. I definitely am aware of how fortunate I am. I was a radio guy, as I mentioned, and a lot of my friends who hired me to work with them
我的意思是，我们刚刚回顾了一点你的早期职业生涯。我的意思是，你绝对站在了你那座山峰的顶端，你在人员方面没有做过任何花招。就像你依然保持着本色，而你正处于你所从事行业的顶端。伴随这一切，一定有一种奇妙的冲动感吧，是的？我的意思是，你应该感到非常骄傲，我确信你也是。我当然清楚自己有多么幸运。我以前是个电台小子，正如我所提到的，很多雇我跟他们一起工作的朋克朋友——
are, they're not doing anything now or that business dried up, and I am so lucky that I happen to be doing radio in Los Angeles where television producers contacted me and have some, because if I'd been doing the same thing in Detroit, I don't know what I'd be doing right now. I really have no idea. Maybe I'd be working at an ad agency or something, but the radio business is a tough one, and it is weird to, when you do look at Wikipedia page and to see these things and to go, wow, I've done a lot of stuff.
他们现在什么都不做了，或者那个行业枯竭了，而我太幸运了，碰巧在洛杉矶做电台，电视制片人联系了我并提供了一些机会，因为如果我在底特律做同样的事，我不知道现在会在做什么。我真的毫无头脑。也许我会在广告公司工作什么的，但电台行业是个艰难的行业，而且很奇妙的是，当你看着自己的维基百科页面看到这些东西，然后心想：哇，我做过这么多事。
It's humbling for sure, and I don't take it for granted, and I do know how lucky I am, and I do think that luck plays a huge part in all of this, and I think, for sure, look at Sean. Yeah, look at him. But let me say this, I've said this to you before, I remember we did a sketch once for your show, or maybe it was for the Emmys or something. Oh, for our Post Oscars show, yeah. Post Oscars show with the Batman, and you had Ben Affleck, and then you had Henry Cavill
这绝对让人感到谦卑，我没有把这一切视为理所当然，我也确实知道自己有多么幸运，而且我真的认为运气在这一切中起到了巨大的作用，并且我认为，绝对的，看看肖恩。对，看着他。但让我这么说吧，我以前对你说过这个，我记得我们有一次为你的节目拍过一个小品，或者可能是为了艾美奖什么的。哦，为了我们的奥斯卡颁奖典礼后节目，对吧。奥斯卡颁奖典礼后节目，有蝙蝠侠的那期，你请了本·阿弗莱克，然后你请了亨利·卡维尔
and whatever, and then I came on, and then they were like, no, you're not Batman and whatever. I was in it too, fuckface. I was in it. I was a superhero. Dude, I don't know. I was a superhero. No, that was a different bit, Jason.
之类的人，然后我出场了，然后他们就说，不，你不是蝙蝠侠之类的。我也演了，混蛋。我演了。我是一个超级英雄。老兄，我不知道。我是一个超级英雄。不，那是另一个段子，杰森。
That was for his family for like a Christmas. Anyway, so this is for major broadcast, Post Oscars show, huge ratings, huge, Ivanka is the best. And Brady wants the dator, sorry, I just got lost, I became a, anyway, but you did, you were acting it, you were playing like this sort of dumb guy, like you didn't know what's going on, and you were trying to, and I said to you at the time, I don't know if you remember, there were a lot of actors, and I was like, you were the best actor on that set, you were the best in the scene, did you ever, and I really for real mean this, did you ever think,
那是为他的家庭拍的，类似于圣诞节视频。不管怎样，这是为了大型广播电视网的奥斯卡颁奖典礼后节目，收视率极高，超级高，伊万卡是最棒的。而布雷迪想要约会对象，抱歉，我刚才走神了，我成了一个——不管怎样，但你确实演了，你演的是那种有点像傻瓜的角色，好像你不知道发生了什么，然后你试图——我当时对你说过，我不知道你记不记得，现场有很多演员，而我说：你是那个片场最好的演员，你是那一幕里演得最好的，你有没有——我是真的真心实意这么想的——你有没有想过，
did you want to become like more of a, did you ever think, fuck, I should have done sketch, I should have gone to SNL, or I wanted, was that something that you ever wanted to do because, or no? No, not at all. Okay, so next question, I have some, a follow-up question. It is not something I wanted to do, it's not something that I feel like I'm good at, I appreciate you saying that, I think, Will, that was probably the only time I bothered to actually learn my lines before we shot, I almost never, I marvel at the idea that
你想成为一个更……你有没有想过，操，我本该去演小品，我本该去周六夜现场，或者我想——那是你曾经想做的事吗，因为，还是说没有？不，完全没有。好吧，下一个问题，我还有后续问题。这不是我想做的事，也不是我觉得自己擅长的事。我很感激你这么说，威尔，那大概是我唯一一次在开拍前费心去把台词真正背下来的时候。我几乎从来不——我对这种想法感到惊叹：
other people know their lines, I will write a script myself, and then I can't remember what I'm supposed to say, I did a TV, I did a local TV thing in Seattle when I was starting out, it was one of these things where they get the dish jockeys to host the Friday night horror movie, and I watched it back, I looked at it, and I made a very honest assessment of myself, I decided I am terrible on television, I should not be on television, and I really better make this radio thing work, and I'm not, I'm not joking, I really did, I looked at it and I was like, okay, I'm bad at that, and I can't do that, and so I should just figure out how to do this radio thing, and it never like, you know, being in drama, I
别人居然能记住他们的台词。我自己写了一个剧本，然后我自己都不记得我该说什么了。我做过电视节目——我在西雅图刚出道时做过一个地方电视台的节目，就是那种让DJ去主持周五晚上的恐怖电影的节目，我回看了一下，我审视了它，并对自己做出了非常诚实的评估：我决定我在电视上表现得太烂了，我不应该上电视，我真的最好把电台这行干好。我不是在开玩笑，我真的这么做了，我看着它，心想：好吧，我在这方面很烂，我做不了这个，所以我应该想办法把电台这摊事做好。而且从来没有——你知道的，演戏剧——
was in drama in high school, I took one semester, I know in college rather, I took a semester of acting in college, and the teacher pulled me outside and threatened to have me expelled from Arizona State University, and I'm not kidding, she pulled me outside and I was, it's funny, more than anything, I was interested that she could do that, she said, you're making the other students uncomfortable, because I was just making fun of everybody the whole time, and you are making them insecure, and you are a detriment to this class, and perhaps you should join a sketch comedy group or something, because you are funny, but this is not appropriate, and I was like, really, you can, she said, and I, you know, I can have you thrown out
我高中时演过戏剧，我上过一个学期——我知道是在大学里，我在大学修过一个学期的表演，老师把我叫到外面，威胁要把我从亚利桑那州立大学开除，我不是在开玩笑，她把我叫到外面，而且有趣的是，比起别的，我对她居然能这么做感到很感兴趣。她说：“你让其他学生感到不舒服，”因为我当时一直在嘲笑所有人，“你让他们感到不自信，你是这个班级的毒瘤，也许你应该加入一个素描喜剧团什么的，因为你很有趣，但这不合时宜。”我当时想：“真的吗？你还能……”她说：“我，”你知道的，“我可以把你赶出
of the school, and I said, you can do that, she's like, yeah, I was like, oh, how about that? Well, you know what, that's so similar, one time Jason was doing The Heart to Heart, a movie of the week, and the SAG came on set, and they threatened to have him kicked out of SAG, isn't that a true story? I had to give the mic hard for four weeks. By the way, I do want to get back to Jimmy, and I want to say one thing, which was, you asked him, you said, do you ever get excited or whatever, do you ever get a charge or a
学校。”我说：“你能做到那样？”她说：“对啊。”我说：“哦，这样啊？”好吧，你知道吗，这太像了，有一次杰森在拍《心心相印》，一部每周电视电影，美国演员工会的人来到片场，他们威胁要把他踢出演员工会，这不是个真事吗？我不得不连续四周交出会费。顺便说一句，我确实想回到吉米这里，我想说一件事，那就是，你问过他，你说，你有没有过兴奋或者别的什么，你有没有过那种冲动、
thrill or some bullshit? I said rush. Rush, do you ever get a rush? Great band. But, and I will say great band, Kelly Lee, anyway, Canadian. But what I wanted to say was, I wanted to ask you, I know you might not get a rush and you kind of laughed like, rush, and I know it's your job, but when you hosted the Oscars that time, that there was the big snafu at the end, when Warren Beatty read the wrong
刺激或者别的什么狗屁感觉？我说的是“冲动”。冲动，你有没有过那种冲动？很棒的乐队。但是，我也要说，这是一支很棒的乐队，凯莉·李，不管怎样，加拿大的。但我想说的是，我想问你——我知道你可能不会有什么冲动，而且你当时笑得像是：冲动？——我也知道这是你的工作，但当你那次主持奥斯卡时，结尾出了那个大乌龙，当沃伦·比蒂读错了
thing, and then all that whole thing, and then you brought those people, you brought those people. You're right, I did enjoy that. Into the theater. And I could see in the moment, you were so enjoying it. I couldn't wait to talk to you about it, because you were so filled with glee. Wait, what happened? When things go wrong, tell me what happened.
东西，然后发生了一连串的事，然后你把那些人，你把那些人——你说得对，我确实很享受那个。带进了剧院。我当时就能看出，你乐在其中。我迫不及待地想跟你聊聊这事，因为你当时充满了狂喜。等等，发生了什么？当事情出错时，告诉我发生了什么。
You opened this side door. So, wait, but Warren Beatty got the wrong envelope, is that what happened? Yeah, he said La La Land, but it was. Moonlight, right? Moonlight, yeah. Do you not remember that? So, yeah, but what were the mechanics of it? He got the wrong envelope.
你打开了这扇侧门。所以，等等，沃伦·比蒂拿错了信封，是这样吗？对，他念了《爱乐之城》，但实际上是——《月光男孩》，对吧？《月光男孩》，对。你不记得了吗？所以，是的，但那背后的机制是什么？他拿错了信封。
Just the show collapsed. There was mass confusion. Nobody knew what to do. He read the wrong best picture. Anyway, that's not. We didn't know what happened. And you're killing me. No, but no, he...
整个节目直接崩溃了。现场一片大混乱。没人知道该怎么办。他念错了最佳影片。不管怎样，这不算。我们根本不知道发生了什么。你把我逗乐了。不，但是，不，他……
There were like 11 minutes of just pure confusion and... It was tremendous. Yeah. The best part about it was I was sitting at a table, I was sitting, I was at that Vanity fair party and I was sitting at a table with Mick Jagger, of course, and laughing with Mick Jagger, who I don't know at all and had not spoken to since, obviously, about what was going on. And the whole time I'm just watching, it really started with the moment you let those people
大概有11分钟纯粹的混乱和——这太震撼了。是的。最棒的部分在于，我当时坐在桌子旁，我坐在——我在那个名利场派对上，我坐在一张桌子旁，旁边当然是米克·贾格尔，我和米克·贾格尔有说有笑——我根本不认识他，而且显然自那以后再没跟他说过话——讨论着到底发生了什么。而整个过程我都在旁观，这一切其实就是从你让那些人
on the street, he opened the side door and he brought a tour and they had no idea and he brought them into the theater. And then watching all the people in the front kind of pretending to be cool with it, but they're not. And they're bummed that you're kind of ruining their big party, but simultaneously know, smart enough to know that they're on camera so they don't want to reveal how pissed off they are. And it's such fucking bullshit as you know. And then, and watching you experience it and knowing in the split second that you're enjoying
走到街上、你打开侧门并带进来一个旅游团开始的，他们完全状况外，而你把他们带进了剧院。然后看着前排的所有人一边假装对这一切泰然处自，一边其实根本不是。他们心里很不爽，觉得你把他们的大派对给搅和了，但同时又足够聪明，知道自己正在镜头前，所以不想表现出自己有多生气。正如你所知，这他妈简直太荒谬了。然后，看着你亲历这一切，并在那一分一秒中知道你正享受着
exactly that dynamic was so fucking great. And then it went all the way to the end with the mishap with the name that you love. You love mayhem. I will tell you, this is something I don't think I've ever explained to anyone. But every time I do an award show or a big show like that, you know, everything's written and we work hard and try to make sure everything is as good as it can possibly be. But I always allow myself one moment in which we just roll the dice and we have no idea it could be a complete disaster.
正是这种动态，这简直他妈的太棒了。然后一直持续到最后那个你最喜欢的名字乌龙事件。你就是喜欢这种混乱。我告诉你，这是我觉得自己从来没向任何人解释过的事。但每次我主持颁奖典礼或这样的大型晚会时，你知道的，一切都是写好的，我们努力工作，试图确保一切都尽善尽美。但我总是允许自己有这样一个时刻：我们直接掷骰子，完全不知道接下来会发生一场彻底的灾难，
It could be great. There's an unknown element because I think when you have that, it makes the show more interesting and everyone who complains that the Oscars where these people complain that like, oh, it's too, it's boring. It's long. It's whatever. And then you throw something like that into the mix and they're like, well, that shouldn't have been in there.
还是会大获成功。这里面有一个未知元素，因为我觉得当你拥有这个元素时，节目会变得更有趣，而所有那些抱怨奥斯卡的人——那些抱怨“哦，这太无聊了、太长了、太怎样怎样”的人，然后你把这种突发状况扔进混战里，他们又会说“嗯，那本不该发生”。
You know, they want it both ways. But I do like that. No one enjoys the feeling of bombing more than I do because I almost feel like I'm watching a prank happen to me. And I do get a thrill out of it. Who is the comic that would go out there and bomb on purpose? There was a stand up that did that. And I just thought that was just so bold.
你知道的，他们两头都想占。但我确实喜欢那样。没有人比我更享受那种搞砸（bombing）的感觉了，因为我几乎觉得我正在看着一场针对我自己的恶作剧发生。我确实从中得到了刺激。哪个喜剧演员会故意上台去搞砸的？有个单口喜剧演员就是这么干的。我当时觉得那真是太大胆了。
Oh, Brody, Brody Stevens. Yeah, Brody Stevens. And it just makes the audience uncomfortable like that. It's basically performance art. Yeah. I mean, I just. Brody, too, he loves to bomb and he loves to be, you have a share, a similar sensibility. I think all you guys do, and I think it's part of the deal.
哦，布罗迪，布罗迪·史蒂文斯。对，布罗迪·史蒂文斯。那会让观众感到很不舒服。这基本上就是行为艺术。对。我的意思是，我只是……布罗迪也是，他喜欢搞砸，他喜欢那种——你们俩有相似的敏感度。我想你们所有人都有，我觉得这也是交易的一部分。
Most people that we know that we like are people who love it when the jokes on them and you, because it's fucking funny. I'll have to do with security, right? You don't give a shit. Well, it's also understanding the basics of comedy, which is that it's all vulnerability, right? I do care. I definitely give a shit and, you know, whatever.
我们认识并喜欢的大多数人，都是那些喜欢拿自己开涮的人，因为这他妈太好玩了。这肯定跟安全感有关，对吧？你根本不在乎。嗯，这也是对喜剧基础的理解，那就是：这一切全都是关于脆弱性，对吧？我在乎。我绝对在乎，而且，管他呢。
But there's just something very funny to me about being in the middle of a situation that is not going well. And I even, I'll take that into my, my regular life, you know, I look ahead so that I can look back. I know that this is going to be funny when I tell it to someone and it makes the bad experiences easier. That gets us to this year's Emmys. Can we talk a little bit about, because I'll bet you this will air right before that.
但在一个进展并不顺利的局面中身处其中，对我来说有某种非常搞笑的特质。我甚至会把这种心态带入我的日常生活，你知道的，我向前看，好让日后能够回味。我知道当我以后把这事讲给别人听时会觉得很好笑，这让那些糟糕的经历变得更容易忍受了。这就说到了今年的艾美奖。我们可以聊聊这个吗？因为我敢打赌这期节目会在那之前播出。
And Jason is nominated twice. That's right. I have not checked. At least twice. I have not checked. Three times. I think best show, best director, best actor. Oh, is it three?
而且杰森获得了两次提名。没错。我还没查。至少两次。我还没查。三次。我想是最佳剧集、最佳导演、最佳男主角。哦，有三个吗？
Is this news? Wait. The nominations are out. No, guys. Now listen, Jimmy, this is going to be a very atypical year for the Emmys in that it will be. Someone's going to die. It will be.
这是新闻吗？等等。提名已经出来了。不，伙计们。听着，吉米，对于艾美奖来说，这将是非常非典型的一年，因为——有人要死了。那将是掷骰子决定的。不，它会在电视上播出，但那将是从电脑上发射信号，就像你的节目每晚那样，对吧？或者现在任何电视节目都是这样。我的意思是，它会从电脑上发射信号，但如果你仔细想想，所有的电视节目其实都是这样的。对。这将在一个大剧院里举行。
That's the role of the dice. No, it will be on television, but that will be beamed from computers, much like your show is every night, right? Or any, any television show is right now. I mean, it will be beamed from computers, but if you think about it, all television shows are. Right. This will take place in a, in a big theater.
呃-huh。我不确定我是不是应该说。好吧。具体哪个剧院，但它会举行。而且我们不一定会有现场观众。好吧。而且，嗯，因为当我读到“艾美奖将以虚拟形式举行”时，我想到的全部就是：把所有提名者的 Zoom 画面都连上去，然后公布赢家，那该有多尴尬啊。
Uh-huh. I'm not sure if I'm supposed to say. Okay. What theater, but it will. And we won't necessarily have an audience. Okay. And, um, well, because all I imagine when I read that, this is going to happen, the Emmys virtually is how embarrassing it might be to have everybody on the zoom who had nominated
然后当每个人都直接点击退出……我不知道，那该怎么运作？你只要点击“停止视频”，对，离开会议，离开会议就行了。希望如此。我的意思是，如果他们把镜头一直停留在失败者身上，那可就太糟糕了，不过你在演播室现场观众中其实也能做到这一点。你知道的，你——你确实会把镜头留在获胜者身上。我觉得那是对的。
and then the winner. And then as everybody just click off, I don't know how does that work? You just click stop video, yeah, leave meeting, leave meeting. I hope so. I mean, it would be bad if they just stayed on the losers the whole time, but you could do that when you're in a studio audience too. You know, you, you, you know, you do kind of stay with the winner. I think that's right.
但所以，结合你刚才说的——老实说，为了确保节目对观众来说质量过硬而付出的那些严肃的成年人的努力，你们这些人在其中辛勤工作，确保一切都令人愉悦地可预测、一切都万无一失，但随后你有时又会让人感觉它稍微有点摇晃。对于今年的艾美奖，在机械层面上一切都有那么多不确定因素的情况下，你能把一场可预测的广播级颁奖典礼搭建到什么程度？这一切对你们来说都挺明朗的，还是说你们还在摸索中？
But so with, with what you were saying about really what the, honestly, the serious adult work that happens to make sure that the product is good for the audience, where you guys work so hard to make sure everything is, is, is pleasurably predictable and it's all buttoned up, but then you let it kind of wobble a little bit sometimes. How much can you build a predictable broadcast of this year's Emmys when I would assume so much is up in the air as far as the literally the mechanics of it all is, is it all pretty clear to you guys or, or are you kind of still kind of figuring it out? It's about 67% clear.
大概有67%是明朗的。
You know, we know that we're going to give out the awards. We know that there's going to be a monologue. There won't be a ton of energy in the room that we know that's going to be, you know, it's, you know, that end of the Oscars where everyone was silent and confused. That's what we're going to go on for three hours. I can't wait for that. That's going to be my favorite part. So it's going to, so the run time will be the same.
你知道的，我们知道我们要颁奖。我们知道会有开场独白。现场不会有什么活力，你知道的，那会是，你知道的，就像奥斯卡那个大家都很安静、很困惑的结尾。我们将要连续进行三个小时这样的节目。我等不及了。那将是我最喜欢的部分。所以，所以节目时长会是一样的。
The run time will be the same. You know how like baseball pipes in a fake crowd noise now, so like name another sport you've got. Well, what about like the, the DNC and, and the RNC will have aired by now. And like, so it's kind of the same type of effort, right? They're all trying to figure out how to do this without a big room and a big audience. You getting any ideas from the DNC? Yeah.
节目时长会是一样的。你知道现在棒球比赛是怎么加入现场假观众欢呼声的吗，所以随便说出你的另一个运动。好吧，比如民主党全国代表大会和共和党全国代表大会到那时都已经播出了。所以这其实是差不多的努力，对吧？他们都在想办法在没有大房间和大量观众的情况下如何做到这一点。你从民主党全国代表大会上得到什么灵感了吗？是的。
I think mostly the ideas are, are what not to do. Not that they haven't put together a pretty good show. I think they have, but there are a lot of really deathly silent moments on that show. And I don't think, but that's politics. You can get away with that. I don't think I'll be able to get away with that. So I think- Jason, are you going to go Jason?
我想大部分的灵感都是，关于不该做什么。并不是说他们没有组织一场相当不错的演出。我认为他们做到了，但那个节目中有很多非常死一般的寂静时刻。我不认为，但那是政治。你可以蒙混过关。我觉得我可能蒙混不过关。所以我觉得——杰森，你要去吗，杰森？
Are you going to get dressed up in a tux at home with Amanda next to you? Yeah. I have no idea. It's, it's actually, it's all in, in real time conversations right now. And I think it's a combination of us, the nominees, waiting to hear from Jimmy, the show about what they want. And then Jimmy, the show is waiting to see what the talent is all comfortable with about, it's a really interesting thing.
你会在家里穿着礼服，旁边坐着阿曼达吗？是的。我完全不知道，这，这其实是目前正在进行的实时对话。我觉得这结合了我们这些被提名者等待吉米和节目组关于他们想要什么的通知。然后吉米和节目组在等待看看嘉宾们对什么感到舒适，这真的是一件很有趣的事。
The community is trying to figure out right now and there's a good spirit to it. I'd hope that if you do wear the tux on the top that you'll keep the pajama bottoms on the bottom. Yeah. That's a weird thing. You just waste up, dress up, waste up. That's, that's all you need. It's a good slogan for this year's show.
整个行业现在都在努力弄清楚这一点，而且其中有一种很好的精神。我希望如果你上半身穿了礼服，下半身能一直穿着睡裤。是的。那是件奇怪的事。你只需上半身，盛装打扮，上半身。那就够了。这可以说是今年节目的一句好口号。
It's a waste up. Yeah. All right. So speaking of entertaining shows for the audience, you had a great show in Texas. It was just you and one other incredible politician that you referred to as Blob Fish. So Blob Fish wanted to kick your ass at a basketball game. His name's Ted Cruz. You got very close to beating him, but ultimately did not win, you lost 11 to nine.
只讲上半身。好吧。说到为观众带来精彩的节目，你在德克萨斯州有一场很棒的演出。当时只有你和另一位了不起的政治家，你称他为大眼狮子鱼。所以大眼狮子鱼想在篮球赛里把你打得屁滚尿流。他叫特德·克鲁兹。你差点就赢了他，但最终没赢，你以11比9输了。
And I remember that you, uh, you couldn't walk for a week after that back home here. Yeah. We, there was a big mistake. And I think that reminds me a lot, Jason, didn't you say that camping trick with life? You couldn't walk for a week. Yeah. Sorry. Keep going.
我记得你，呃，回家后有一个星期都走不了路。是的。我们，那是一个大错误。我觉得这让我想起了很多，杰森，你不是说过那个关于生活的露营恶作剧吗？你有一个星期走不了路。是的。抱歉。继续。
The walking was fine. The sitting was tough. I, uh, I think that the mistake that I made was not having no fouls. We decided there'd be no fouls called because in my head, I was imagining him calling fouls on everything and it just being like just boring and going on forever. So let's just have no fouls. And I thought that we would play in a reasonable way, but I should have known that Ted Cruz was not going to play in a, in a normal way because he doesn't do anything normal.
走路还好，坐着可真要命。我，呃，我觉得我犯的错误是没有设置犯规。我们决定不吹任何犯规，因为在我的脑海里，我幻想着他会对所有事情都吹犯规，那就会变得很无聊而且没完没了。所以索性就不要有犯规了。我以为我们会以合理的方式打球，但我早该知道特德·克鲁兹不会以正常的方式打球，因为他做的任何事都不正常。
And I mean, it was practically like he would put me, and I'm not exaggerating. Like if you were to watch the raw video, he would put me in a bear hug while I was dribbling. I mean, it was just like, like, are we even playing basketball now, what's going on? That must have taken forever. What's he like as a person? He's a nice enough guy. What's he like? Is he a hugger?
我的意思是，那简直就像他要把我，我可没夸张。如果你看原始视频，他在我运球时会给我来个熊抱。我的意思是，那简直就像是——我们现在到底还在打篮球吗？这算怎么回事？那一定花了很长时间。他作为一个人是什么样的人？他是个挺不错的人。他是什么样的人？他喜欢拥抱别人吗？
Is he a good hugger? He's a friendly enough guy and, uh, you know, we raised money for charity and the whole thing was a positive overall, but I would have liked to have won that game and, uh, I was, uh, ashamed of myself. I, you know, I made the mistake of trying to really become a good basketball player the week before the game. So when I was, you know, when, when I got there, I was already in bad shape physically and when I left, I was in worse shape physically.
他是个喜欢拥抱的人吗？他是个挺友好的人，而且，你知道的，我们为慈善事业筹款，整个活动总体来说是很积极的，但我本希望赢得那场比赛，而且，我，呃，我对自己感到羞愧。我，你知道的，我犯了一个错误，在比赛前一个星期真的试图成为一名优秀的篮球选手。所以当我，你知道的，当我到达那里时，我的身体状况已经很糟了，而当我离开时，我的身体状况更糟了。
What stiffened up on you? I forget. Was it your back or your legs afterwards? Um, nothing really. I, I, I tore some, something in my, uh, like, uh, pelvis. Oh God. Yeah. Do you see your pelvis stiffened up?
你身上哪里僵硬了？我忘了。是你的背部还是腿部？呃，其实没什么，我，我，我撕裂了，我的一些，呃，比如骨盆里的东西。哦天哪。是啊。你看，你的骨盆都僵硬了。
Yep. Copy. So any chance. Listen, I'm just trying to keep it rolling along here. What about, what about a rematch on that? Um, let's get a rematch going and let's televise it and let's raise money for, um, some sort of, uh, uh, political race in Texas. Well, here's the thing.
没错。收到。那么还有没有可能。听着，我只是想让谈话继续进行下去。那关于，关于再打一场复赛呢？呃，我们来安排一场复赛，把它电视直播出去，然后为，呃，德克萨斯州的某种，呃，政治竞选筹款。好吧，事情是这样的。
The reason that, that I did it is because, uh, obviously I wanted Beto to win that then and, and I knew that, uh, that was unlikely and that Ted Cruz had a big lead. But I is somewhere in the, in the back of my head, I thought, if I can get him to throw up on television during this game, this is going to be a devastating visual. And perhaps it is just the Hail Mary that, that we need to, to win that seat. Do you think he got close? Uh, I got close, but, uh, There's a Jimmy loves chaos and then there's the best example that that's such a perfect
我之所以那样做是因为，呃，很显然我当时希望贝托赢，而且，我知道，呃，那不太可能，特德·克鲁兹当时的优势很大。但我，在我的脑海深处，我在想，如果我能让他在比赛期间在电视上吐出来，这将是一个毁灭性的视觉效果。也许这就是我们赢得那个席位所需的最后一搏。你觉得他快撑不住了吗？呃，我快成功了，但，呃，吉米喜欢混乱，而这正是最完美的例子，
of, I totally believe that. Yeah. And all the great humor that's on your show, the incredible writing staff, uh, congratulations again for another nomination. Now at the top of the heap there, uh, you've fallen in love with, uh, one of those top writers over there, Molly McNearney, and, uh, and you've, you've married her, you appropriated with her. Yeah.
我完全相信这一点。是的。还有你节目中所有精彩的幽默，了不起的编剧团队，呃，再次恭喜你获得又一次提名。现在你处于顶峰，呃，你爱上了，呃，那里的顶级编剧之一，莫莉·麦克内尼，而且，呃，你和她结婚了，你和她结合了。是的。
Um, so tell us what it is like to work with your wife, the complications of that, the pluses, the minuses and try not to talk yourself into a divorce right now. Let's see if you can wiggle in some problems. No, what's it like to like your wife? Yeah. That's fascinating. Well, um, I think it's great. I honestly don't, there are no negatives, uh, as far as working together goes.
那么，给我们讲讲和你的妻子一起工作是什么感觉，其中的复杂性、积极面、消极面，并尽量现在不要把自己说得要离婚了。让我们看看你能不能从一些问题中摆脱出来。不，喜欢你的妻子是什么感觉？是的。这太迷人了。嗯，我觉得这很棒。老实说，我不觉得，就共同工作而言，没有任何负面影响。
It's, we have the same vacation schedule. Um, I feel like, like I'll do sometimes I'll, I will sometimes dream a joke or think of something in the middle of the night. And then what I do is, because I cannot hold it in, I will, um, I won't say how I make noise, but I won't be as quiet as I normally am until I could see that she is stirring. And then once she's just happens to be awake, I'll tell her what I thought. And part of it, uh, in my, deep in my skull, I think that I go like, well, this is her job.
我们有相同的休假时间。呃，我觉得，有时候我会，我有时会在半夜梦到一个笑话或想到一些事情。然后我会怎么做呢，因为我憋不住，我会，呃，我不会说我是怎么制造噪音的，但我不会像平时那样安静，直到我看到她开始翻身。然后一旦她刚好醒了，我就会告诉她我的想法。其中一部分，呃，在我脑海深处，我想我会觉得，嗯，这是她的工作。
So, you know, it is okay for me to, to do this. Like that's how I rationalize it. So you're doing pitch sessions in the middle of the night cause you can't wait till the morning. She could sue you for overtime. Yeah. Or just write it down like somebody does with dreams. I found that when I write things down in the middle of the night, I have no idea what
所以，你知道的，我这样做是可以的。就像我是这样合理化它的。所以你大半夜在进行推敲会议，因为你等不到早晨？她可以告你索要加班费。是的。或者像别人做梦那样把它写下来。我发现当我在半夜把事情写下来时，我完全不知道
they say the next day. I, I, I cannot, I can't even, they don't even look like letters. They're, it's just pure nonsense. You can articulate it to your wife. And it drives me, she remembers you. It drives me crazy when I think something was really funny and I write it down and then I cannot for the life of me figure out what it was the next day. And then you narcoleptic right back to bed and she's up working on the job.
第二天它们写的是什么。我，我，我甚至，它们看起来甚至都不像字母。它们，纯粹就是胡言乱语。你可以把它向你的妻子表达清楚。这让我，她还记得。每当我以为某个点子真的很搞笑并把它写下来，结果第二天怎么也想不起来它是什么时，我都快疯了。然后你又立马嗜睡症发作睡回床上，而她还在熬夜工作。
Exactly. I go right back to sleep. And then she's like, what is going on in my life? That's perfect. Sean, Sean, you told me the other, the other week that you woke up and you wrote something down and then you read it in the morning and it was just simply said, do you like whipped cream? And then, and then in the middle of the night, I sleepwalk.
没错。我马上又睡着了。然后她会想：我的生活到底怎么了？这太完美了。肖恩，肖恩，你前几天告诉我，你醒来后写了点东西，然后你在早晨读了它，上面简单写着：你喜欢鲜奶油吗？然后，然后半夜里，我梦游了。
I talked to Trader Joe's and bought 10 cans of whipped cream. I just did whip hits all night to get back to bed. Whipped it. Whipped it good. All right. We've taken enough of your time, you're incredible. I only have another three hours, by the way, I'm very busy right now. Are you doing it?
我跟乔氏超市联系，买了我买了10罐鲜奶油。我整晚都在吸鲜奶油来让自己重新睡着。奶油。奶油用得很棒。好了。我们已经占用你够多时间了，你太棒了。顺便说一句，我只剩下另外三个小时了，我现在很忙。你在做吗？
Are you doing it? You're not doing it. When are you back on the show? I'll be back the Monday after the Emmys, which are when, which are, uh, what September 21st? Well, if this is airing right now, we'll all know when they are, but yeah, right around there. And because I'm not going to have you for at least another week, do you, I just wanted
你在做吗？你没在做。你什么时候回到节目中？我将在艾美奖之后的星期一回来，艾美奖是什么时候，是，呃，9月21日吗？好吧，如果这个节目现在正在播出，我们都会知道它们是什么时候，但是是的，差不多就在那个时候。而且因为至少在接下来的一周里我不能拥有你，你，我只想
to take a second to say thank you. I just had that incredible opportunity of hosting guest hosting your show during this guest host kind of revolving door. Thank you for doing it. And it was super, super, super fun. And it was really truly an honor to share the same space that, that you occupy. And thank you for, uh, participating in our little project with Norman Lear live in front of a studio audience.
花一秒钟的时间说声谢谢。我刚刚获得了那个不可思议的机会，在你的节目寻找客座主持的这段轮换期间担任客座主持。谢谢你让我这么做。这真的，真的很，很有趣。而且能够分享你所占据的空间，真的是一种荣幸。谢谢你，呃，参与我们的那个小项目，和诺曼·利尔一起在演播室现场观众面前演出。
That was a blast. The thing you won the Emmy for last year? Yes. And, uh, we are nominated again this year and, uh, are you going to do more of those? I would like to. Yeah, we have to get a live studio audience back first, but it would be fun to do more of them. It was a lot of fun to do.
那太棒了。就是你去年赢得艾美奖的那个节目？是的。而且，呃，我们今年再次获得提名，呃，你们还要做更多这样的节目吗？我挺想的。是的，我们必须先找回现场演播室观众，但如果能做更多这样的节目会很有趣。制作起来非常有趣。
Yeah. Um, Jimmy, I am, I hope you guys continue doing this, uh, podcast because it's a lot of fun. This is the last one. This is probably our last one. Yeah. I, uh, I, I really just like hearing you guys bust each other's balls. I don't think you need the guests.
是的。呃，吉米，我，我希望你们能继续做这个，呃，播客，因为这非常有趣。这是最后一个了。这可能是我们的最后一个了。是的。我，呃，我真的很喜欢听你们两个互喷。我觉得你们不需要嘉宾。
I think the guests are optional. I think you should do some episodes without guests. Look at how much we learned though. You know, what did we really learn though? We learned, what did we learn? We learned, I learned about your narcolepsy. We learned that radio is dead. We learned that radio is dead.
我觉得嘉宾是可有可无的。我觉得你们应该做一些没有嘉宾的单集。不过看看我们学到了多少东西。你知道，我们到底学到了什么？我们学到了，我们学到了什么？我们学到了，我了解了你的嗜睡症。我们学到了广播已经死了。我们学到了广播已经死了。
We learned, um, all the things that we would have learned if there was no Wikipedia. Right. Now, will you go, will you go nine, nine right now after this is over? Sleep? Yeah. It's one o'clock in the afternoon. Yeah. It's one 20.
我们学到了，呃，所有如果没有维基百科我们本来会学到的东西。对吧。那么，这一切结束后，你会马上去睡9、9个小时吗？睡觉？是的。现在是下午一点。是的，现在是一点二十。
No, I'm going to stay, I'm going to stay up till dark tonight. All right. Jimmy, we love you. Crazy. We love your wife. We love your kids, your show, everything, um, and, and love your generosity for saying yes to coming and talking with us. Thank you.
不，我要熬夜，我要熬夜到今天天黑。好吧。吉米，我们爱你。太疯狂了。我们爱你的妻子，我们爱你的孩子，你的节目，一切，呃，并且，并且感谢你答应来和我们谈话的慷慨。谢谢你。
Thank you. I enjoyed it. Take care. Night night. Good night. Night night. Bye. Love you.
谢谢你们。我很享受。保重。晚安。晚安。晚安。拜拜。爱你们。
Bye. Bye, buddy. Bye. Hey, how lucky are we that we are buddies with that guy? Love him. I just, I, you know, I have less friends. The older I get, the less friends I have, uh, as I'm sure that that's not unique to me.
拜拜。拜拜，兄弟。拜拜。嘿，我们能和那家伙做兄弟，我们是多么幸运啊！爱他。我只是，你知道，我的朋友越来越少了。我越老，朋友就越少，呃，我确信这对我来说不是个例。
Um, you know, people get busy with their families and their careers and whatnot. Like when I was a kid, I used to have like 40 friends, but now I've got like you two and maybe three others and Jimmy's one of those. And it, uh, I feel like I don't need anymore. I've got, uh, quality, uh, folks like you guys. Uh, yeah. Likewise. He's such a great, yeah.
呃，你知道的，人们都被他们的家庭、事业之类的事情搞得很忙。就像我还是个孩子的时候，我曾经有大约40个朋友，但现在我只有你们两个和可能其他三个人，吉米就是其中之一。而且，呃，我觉得我不需要更多了。我有，呃，像你们这样高质量的朋友。呃，是的。彼此彼此。他真的是个很棒的，是的。
I feel the same way. And he's, he's, uh, yeah, I do, as you know, I do very little socializing, um, or texting or texting. I get a lot of flack for that. E-mailing. I know. Or phone calls. What I do, it's like you guys or Jimmy or, or, and you guys, like that's, that's it.
我也有同感。而且他，他，呃，是的，正如你所知，我很少进行社交活动，呃，或者发短信。我为此受到了很多批评。发电子邮件。我知道。或者打电话。我的做法就是，就像你们俩或吉米，或者，而且你们俩，就像这样，就是这样。
I just don't do it. And it's important. Um, but at least when I do do it, I get to do it with quality folks, I will say. So that's. Yeah. And Jimmy's one of those. Yeah. He does.
我只是不怎么社交。这很重要。不过至少当我这样做的时候，我能和高质量的人一起做，我得这么说。所以就是这样。是的。吉米就是其中之一。是的。他确实如此。
And, uh, works with his, his, his being a dad as much as he does and husband, um, and still has time to do a podcast every once in a while. Yeah. And I think he's super successful and super accessible because he's just make, he's unapologetic about who he is and his, and his beliefs and his opinions. And I think people are drawn to that. And I am. Yeah.
而且，呃，他尽可能多地陪伴家人、扮演好父亲和丈夫的角色，同时还有时间偶尔做个播客。是的。而且我认为他超级成功，也超级平易近人，因为他只是在做自己，对他是谁以及他的信念和观点毫不掩饰。我认为人们会被这一点吸引。我也是。是的。
One of you guys said, uh, uh, and it's true that he's certainly in the time I've known him, but he's just always stays the same. He is the same guy, such a genuine, authentic guy. He's one of those few, and we know what it's like and we know a lot of people in this town and a lot of people who do what we do. Um, and that's not always the case. Um, so a lot of people who are perceived as one way by the public and then who they really are is completely different.
你们其中一个人曾说过，呃，呃，这确实是真的，就在我认识他的这段时间里，他一直保持着老样子。他还是那个人，一个如此真诚、真实的人。他是少数几个人之一，我们知道这是什么感觉，我们在这个圈子里认识很多人，也有很多人做着我们所做的事。呃，但情况并非总是如此。呃，所以很多人被公众认为是一种样子，但他们真实的自我却完全不同。
And there are lots of instances that we know of that we've all talked about who are like that or people like, no way, that person's a dick. They seem so nice. And he's one of those people who is just so genuinely who he is. There's no switch that he throws when he's in front of the camera. He's exactly the same guy, so comfortable in his skin, which is, and so surprising to hear that he, you know, was originally when he first saw himself on television, you told us that story was like, oh, no, I'm, I look uncomfortable.
我们知道有很多这样的例子，我们都讨论过这样的人，或者有人会说：不会吧，那个人是个混蛋。他们看起来那么好。而他是那种真正做自己的人。当他在镜头前时，他没有任何伪装。他完全是同一个人，对自己的状态如此舒适，这让人感到惊讶，当你听说他，你知道的，最初当他第一次在电视上看到自己时，你告诉我们那个故事说：哦，不，我很不自在。
I don't like the way I look or I'm not comfortable. It's amazing that he is like, that's for me as a viewer. That's why I'm attracted to, you know, watching his show. And especially at that time of night, we, you don't want any nonsense. You want somebody, you want to welcome them into your house if they're, if they're, if they put you at ease and he's always at ease with himself and it's, it's infectious. Yeah. I think people would be surprised to learn like, Will, when they meet you in person that
我不喜欢我自己的样子，或者我不自在。真令人惊叹，他竟然是这样，对我来说作为一个观众。这就是为什么我被吸引去，你知道的，看他的节目。尤其是在一天中的那个时间，你不需要任何废话。你需要一个人，如果你感到放松，你会欢迎他们进入你的家，而他在面对自己时总是那么放松，而且这种放松是会传染的。是的。我想人们会惊讶地发现，威尔，当他们亲自见到你时
that's not your real skin or hair comfortable in my real skin is why I don't show them my real skin or the wires, the wires and everything that keeps it together. But you know what? When you've had as much work done as I have, which is, and I'll admit it, extensive, you know, you've, it takes a lot of, it's a lot of rubber bands and Scotch tape over here, you know, just to, you know, show my, you've lived through two world wars, I've been around a minute. I've been around a minute.
那不是你的真实皮肤或头发。对我真实的皮肤感到舒适，这就是为什么我不让他们看我的真实皮肤，或者是那些电线，以及把它固定在一起的所有电线。但你知道吗？当你做过跟我一样多的医美手术——而且我会承认，这是大量的——你知道的，你，这需要很多，这里有很多橡皮筋和透明胶带，你知道的，只是为了，你知道的，展示我的——你经历过两次世界大战，我已经存在一会儿了。我已经存在一会儿了。
Don't look at day over 40. Unbelievable. You know, when I, I guess hosted his show back when he took a leave right after Billy was born and I remember just, we don't even need to have this on the show, but I just remember being so thinking about what a great guy is as I was hosting this show and saying, Jimmy's not here because his son Billy's in the hospital and then immediately starting to well up as I'm delivering the fucking monologue in front of the audience. And I'm like, he's such a fucking great guy who deserves only great things.
看起来连40岁都不到。难以置信。你知道的，当我在比利出生后不久他请假时，我曾客串过他的节目，我只记得——我们甚至不需要在节目中播放这段，但我只记得在主持节目的同时，一直在想他是个多好的人，并说道：吉米现在不在，因为他的儿子比利在住院。然后当我在观众面前念着该死的开场独白时，眼泪立刻涌了上来。我想：他真的是个该死的绝世好人，只配得上所有美好的事物。
And he's such a wonderful person and love him so much. And you just think like, you know, This is a good, good lesson about, you know, want to read the monologue through first. No, I like to wing it. Before you get up there. Yeah. I like to wing it. Cold reading the monologue while we're rolling.
他是一个如此精彩的人，我太爱他了。你会想，你知道的，这是一个很好的教训，关于——你想先把独白读一遍吗？不，我喜欢临场发挥。在你上台之前。是的。我喜欢临场发挥。在录制的同时冷读独白。
It's not, not a good idea. Yeah. You know what? My president does that. And he's the president. So, that takes us right to the bay. Smart. What?
这不是，不是个好主意。是的。你知道吗？我的总统就是那样做的。而他是总统。所以，这就直接带我们到了——很聪明。什么？
Smart. What? Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。什么？聪明。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。